make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin okay
so we're getting back into deceased and
and here's the funny thing we did skip
over a couple of the stories that are
not directly tied into what we did
before
and and the reason why is because one of
the things that i've learned about tom
taylor is that it's usually best to kind
of let him
finish his thought finish his story and
then go back to the individual tie-ins
and just kind of see
what those have to offer in relation to
the to the main story itself but in the
previous video we had talked about how
black adam's anti-life army was
basically rising right the black adam
was leading this massive anti-life army
where he had infected
almost the entirety of his own kingdom
and then from there his attention turned
to yotenheim which was kind of like this
last bastion right this fortress
was kind of this impenetrable place
right the only way to really access it
was to
to enter in through a a smaller hole now
the thing about yotenheim is this didn't
really take into account the idea of
like superpowered beings trying to break
into it right it was a fortress that was
built to hold off what amounted to just
regular people but the important thing
here is that wonder woman's more or less
trying to hold it up right to keep the
innocent people inside safe since there
are innocent people who were fleeing
trying to get away from the infection
now with the arrival of black adam where
he goes in for the kill he's immediately
knocked away and the reason why is
because what wonder woman had done is
she had sent out an
sos to the other members of the justice
league right trust of superman to black
canary who i guess we can call her just
the green canary green lantern we can
just call her green lantern
uh cyborg and martian manhunter right so
of course this takes place before all
those various heroes fall and with them
being here they offer some much needed
assistance
the stress on wonder woman holding up
this basically the side of a mountain
is way too much right so with green
lantern using her power that basically
allows her to kind of hold the place up
which is almost effortless for her and
then in turn superman just kind of hits
up and says okay
you have infected in there who were
chasing after those people we have to
try to find a way to save them but at
the same time they're also focusing on
this idea of trying to destroy black
adam because the truth is that he's the
immediate threat right he's the biggest
threat here now the other part of this
is that when it comes to the the
survivors who are left inside you have a
few here and there uh you've got a few
people who were who are basically
surviving as best they can raza of
course the character that we talked
about in one of the previous videos but
for the most part
a lot of them are really just kind of
being cornered and it doesn't really
seem to be a lot of hope against all
these various forces that are calling
their way through
only for us to basically be met with the
arrival of hawkman and hawkgirl and this
is cool
right it's not the biggest moment ever
but i feel like for hawkman and hot girl
fans it's like yes
you know because from there they start
doing what they do best which is just
ripping away just tearing away all these
different these different undead
and forcing them back to where they came
from right forcing them back through
this this nightshade portal and back to
where
you know the darkness wherever it is
they're being held at the moment so what
it does is it gives them a moment of
reprieve but not exceedingly long
because before the portal closes
carter hall is snatched up and basically
yanked into into the darkness and this
is kind of a cool thing right and
and here's what i would like to have
seen here right because all you really
get is all these these you know undead
forces here however many are there right
because we don't even really know how
many are there but however many are
being held in this you know
what they call the land of the
nightshades but however many are being
held there you don't really get to see
what happens and i
really feel like this would have been a
cool moment if it was like jonathan
hickman's fantastic four where like
johnny storm ended up being trapped in
the negative zone against like an army
of
the annihilation wave and he just turns
around and he's just like flying on
right it's just like it just cuts and
it's just like dude is like one of the
most epic moments
ever in the history of johnny storm but
then you end up seeing what happens
later on um i
kind of wish we would have gotten to see
like this huge battle taking place you
know between
uh between hawkman and like all these
different undead here right because the
funny thing about hawkman is he he he's
easy to look at it's like a character
and easy to kind of dismiss him and just
be like he's a guy who basically dies
and comes back to life and he's got some
wings and you know yeah a mace you know
is made of benth metal and who really
cares right like the guy's basically
basically a gladiator dressed like a
bird it's very easy to throw him away
in that way but hawkman really has it
where it counts
right like if there's any guy you want
on your side in a conflict it's hawkman
right between like his super strength
his ability to fly his battle harden and
especially his experience over the
multiple lives that he's lived
he's a guy you want in your corner and
it's it's kind of disappointing to see
that like you don't really get to see
this great big huge long drawn out
conflict
it would have been interesting but the
long and short of this is that it takes
the combined efforts of superman
and cyborg and martian manhunter to
basically you know hold off black adam
while the
people inside yotenheim right basically
green lantern uses their power to kind
of carry the island away and across the
water and as they're making their way
black adam suddenly stops and basically
holds off and the question's asked like
what's what's going on like what in the
world is happening here and the response
is
basically it realizes it's outnumbered
right and it's not really black adam
realizing this it's the anti-life
realizing this and this is cool this is
a cool solidification because what it
means
is it points to this idea that the
anti-life equation is
is a is a singular hive mind that it's
not individuals acting
individually while they're infected with
the anti-life equation that the virus
itself
shares a singular mind and that all
these different individuals are just
facsimiles of itself
it's like you controlling your fingers
and it's kind of a cool thing it's an
awesome idea right like it's it's an
amazing concept it's kind of been hit on
over the course of the original deceased
comics so it's not a wholly new concept
but it is cool to see a reference in
that way now of course this leads to
cyborg realizing that something's coming
in and of course we end up finding out
that it's eerie right
he's looking for wink which is the girl
with the ability to kind of teleport
more or less that the two of them of
course we talked about in a previous
video then everything's okay as far as
as far as wink goes and of course iris
you know travels back to yotenheim finds
wink and of course you end up having a
kendra who's basically recovering or at
least struggling with the idea that
carter hall's more or less been taken
away been captured and that's when
things kind of begin to pop off because
what we end up finding out here is the
reason why black adam really stopped is
because of the fact it has nothing to do
with the water it has nothing to do with
the belief that he was outnumbered
it basically has everything to do with
the fact that hawkman's completely and
totally infected not only that
hawkman is the one who's going to lead
the anti-life army
not black adam black adam is not the one
running the show that is carter hall and
that's a cool concept because it really
kind of begs the question
what will happen with carter hall
running all this right because he is a
hoss he's a demon and i doubt that
kendra's gonna have the fortitude to
kill him if it comes down to it but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you